good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
actually Monday but tomorrow we have a
show at Carnegie Hall we're going to be
kind of busy so I'm coming to you from
the halcyon years of yesterday so Hank
we're all here in New York City I should
probably stop filming these people
because they think that I'm like
creeping on their offices but the trip
here was a bit of a nightmare for you
and Katherine it involved planes and
trains and automobiles and delayed
flights and missed connections and then
it culminated with lost baggage and in
the end it took you 23 hours to get from
Missoula to New York which is excellent
by stagecoach standards but quite poor
for 21st century air travel anyway
hopefully your guitar will get here
before you have to play songs on it at
Carnegie Hall meanwhile I was sleeping
so Hank I dreamt that chick-fil-a opened
up four restaurants in North Korea and
in my dream I was like I don't know what
I should make a video about today oh
right I should definitely make a video
about chick-fil-a opening up restaurants
in North Korea and then I woke up and I
was like god chick-fil-a why don't you
get in bed with Kim Jong Un's who has
something to make a video about okay got
to go to our rehearsal walk with me
that's the Sun that Hanks anxiety makes
guess who it is
you'll never guess what it's give you
daughter the backstage Hank feverishly
writes down the lyrics to his songs that
he doesn't forget them so we are
backstage at housing works getting ready
for our rehearsals for tomorrow's
Carnegie Hall show here I'll show you
the audience they don't know that I'm
videotaping them there is a man behind
the bookcase first time I saw girls the
day that I hit keep really a beautiful
girl shove my society wasn't her fault
she just some fun lace to me is so
special baby without your PC you'll help
us
we just did our first rehearsal it went
well but it's not the kind of thing you
want to see it Carnegie Hall now we're
gonna go rehearse again I just want to
remind you that you can watch the show
live at youtube.com slash vlogbrothers
at 7 p.m. today which is tomorrow it's
very confusing
Tuesday 7 p.m. Eastern Time also there
are places all around the country and
world where you can watch it there links
in the doobly-doo I can be different of
a different different different
different to this Hank
hi John hi Kim yep hi John Hank I'll see
you right now a also on Friday